In France, this week's edition of the satirical Charlie Hebdo magazine...
...features the Prophet Muhammed.
In France, President Francois Hollande pays tribute to the three police officers,...
...including one Muslim, who was killed in last week's terror attacks.
Pope Francis brings a message of peace and reconciliation in Sri Lanka,...
...on a week-long trip to Asia.
In Mozambique, officials investigate the beer poisoning deaths of 69 people...
...and the government declares three days of mourning.
And finally from Switzerland, Christian Ronaldo beats Lionel Messi and Manuel Neuer...
...for Ballon d'Or soccer player of the year award.